[Music]
hey you guys here we are back once again
zach says i'm sober
[Laughter]
yeah we're sober too so are we i'm just
i i got tea today yeah because i i had
one during the show last night but that
was all i had him take it easy
well today we're going to do son of kong
one of the first
sequels to a blockbuster
yeah in the movie industry
had a lot of the original cast fay ray
wasn't in it they replaced her with
another one i don't know who that is i
actually liked her character better i
liked her helen mack i think her name is
ellen what
helen mack i think her name is mac yeah
i liked her character a little bit
better
and uh it's a very different kind of
movie than kong
it's a lot more like a uh indiana jones
and you can see where
indiana jones was a ripoff of movies
like these
and uh
helen mack i don't remember what her
character is she's a lot like indiana's
girlfriend in the first movie what was
her name uh marion marion kind of
reminds me of marion she's a little more
scrappy
she kind of has a damn personality when
faye was really just dams a little
distressed you know
she just swooned you know but this one
she actually did cool [ __ ]
uh
it was a good movie
they run into kong's son
baby baby call
little kong i think they call him that
sometimes too it's kind of strange
because
this movie is an apology for what
happened to [ __ ] king kong
and it dude says it he said i'm sorry
what happened to your old man you know i
just need to apologize you know what we
took him down and he got killed and
you know it was all for nothing type of
deal pretty much yeah and then um
they all save each other
several times
but baby kong dies anyway
yeah see now oh fist i was like wait a
minute i was you like i thought that
when we were talking about king kong on
sunday
i thought one of y'all in the comments i
don't remember who it was but i thought
somebody in the comments said oh baby
kong or like son of kong like lives at
the end of this movie he absolutely does
not live he's trailer he dies at the end
of this and it's like so i was expecting
him to like live and i was like oh look
how cute he is and everything like that
and then he died i got kind of like
angry and it's like i went i went out
the room like to go to the bathroom like
after a poopy was sitting at the top of
the stairs i'm like do you believe that
[ __ ] pookie yeah they killed off
congress she did not believe it yeah and
he died because he died saving people
so yeah
kind of although they didn't confirm it
they didn't show his dead body
afterwards but you assume he died though
he got
he went underneath the water so he got
well like the whole island got like yeah
we got it was like earthquake
i thought it was a whole island i mean
it was kind of like hard to tell because
it was you know
right
so i wasn't i wasn't really clear either
i thought it was just kind of like a a
little a little um reef that they were
on
i guess it was the whole i thought it
was the whole island yeah so the whole
island sank and that's it no more
monsters
[Laughter]
until the remakes yeah until the remake
or until like it's until a volcano comes
and like pops it up other than all the
dinosaurs and [ __ ] on it yes
was made in the same year they made it
made it just a few months later with i
think half the budget yeah well that's
kind of the thing um
you know i don't really know if they
were expecting king kong to be as large
a cultural phenomenon as it was in 1933
i mean it was a giant giant hit
so basically rko pictures
were um you know they were basically
like oh my god we got to do like more of
this
and
it was like the same producer but it's
like yeah you have to have the whole
movie done and that's writing the script
pre-production actual filming
post-production everything
in nine months they did it in nine
months which is unprecedented i mean
even for back then
so i kind of feel like
i don't know like i liked this movie but
it's not you're not going to be able to
follow king kong for christ's sake i
mean you know what i mean that was kind
of like uh now they did have um the
woman that did the uh the script
doctoring and like kind of did most of
the final version of the script on the
first king kong uh ruth rose she
actually wrote the screenplay for the
second one
and she's basically like well i'm not
gonna be able to top king kong obviously
so she's like maybe i should just make
it funnier or make it like a slightly
different kind of movie now it should be
noted too that a lot of stuff was in the
script that they couldn't afford to put
in the movie so like there was supposed
to be like a big cyclone and there was
supposed to be like a big dinosaur
stampede and like all this other kind of
stuff going on in the movie but they
couldn't afford to show it so
i kind of feel like what happens
is that it's a it's a really good movie
i'm not saying that but it is like
completely different and
it has a lot more humor in it like baby
kong is more of like uh
like you said yeah it's like more like
minia or like you know godzilla like
yeah it's like kazuki like the like the
little baby godzilla
yeah where where there's just kind of
where he get like
you know what i mean this guy is a
ripoff got to be a ripoff of sonic kong
japanese saw that you know and was like
oh yeah we're gonna do that we're gonna
do with godzilla of course yeah so
it works though it's just
you're not gonna be able to do king kong
again
and she knew that so she's basically
well maybe i can just make it a
different kind of story and make it
funnier
and stuff like that so there is a lot
more humor in it now the guy that played
carl denham um in the first movie like
comes back for this one and actually he
ended up liking this one better i guess
because his part's bigger and also like
he gets a hot chick at the end who's
like half his age so i guess he liked
that uh robert armstrong i think that
guy's name is yeah so so he likes this
movie a lot better
and he's more
he's more of a character in this i kind
of feel like in the first king kong he's
kind of like a little bit of a
caricature yeah like uh you know we're
gonna like that's the eighth the wonder
of the world and he's like talking like
a radio broadcast whereas in this one
he's more like a person
like you know what i mean this is
definitely an indiana jones type movie
it's got a lot of the same things
um
girls uh in bars in seaports uh fights
in seaports mutinies
uh exploring new [ __ ] um
but it's got that kinda you know how in
indiana jones he's always dealing with
like merchant marines and
sea vessels and [ __ ] you know guys on
the edges edges of society to where
they're mostly at sea so they don't care
what's going on there's a lot of that in
it
um
he
dude inherits this uh girl
her dad gets killed in a fire day before
and he was a drinker living in that same
scene and she has to go on the voyage
and they said absolutely not so she
stows away she ends up in it anyway
they get it they get to skull island and
the ship and the ship's crew mutinies
and kicks
dude off and the girl and uh the chinese
cook and yeah he returns with the
chinese cook
he ran around the whole time with his
dab with a
cleaver chinese [ __ ] meat cleaver
typical [ __ ] chinese weapon of the
30s
you know that's pretty funny and um
yeah whenever they show chinese people
in the cartoons back in those days
they're running around damn meat cleaver
chasing you around immediately i guess
it was
yeah chinese restaurants that was sister
that's all you ever see dudes on the
street cooking with that meat cleaver so
you know
anyway uh just stereotypes you know
but uh
i thought it was a good movie it was
good movie yeah it's fun it's just don't
expect king kong
expect more kind of like a comedy
semi-comedy version almost more like a
sinbad movie
like a cross between
like sinbad this seven voyages like
seven voyages sinbad something like that
mixed with indiana jones the the lead
character what was his name again the uh
carl denim yeah carl uh he he's kind of
like
kind of like andy kind of
well kind of like more of like a dumpy
middle-aged version of it
[Laughter]
yeah
yeah well you know [ __ ]
harrison ford he upped the game you know
in that genre
he was pretty physically fit for a
professor
you know well because he had to go out
adventuring he had to get out of here he
had to go and do crossfit like one year
like during his off time he had to be
impressive to the ladies
so uh you know
but that guy was
probably not all that shabby for his era
yeah you know
but that's i would say it's a very
similar movie
very similar kind of movie jason
williams says great movie this is a
great podcast have you guys done a show
on female serial killers we've done some
individual female serial killers i think
we did alien warnos and a couple of
other ones but
i don't know like we probably will at
some point because yeah because yeah
uh slasher fred said are you also going
to review the 1976 remake and it's
sequel king kong lives maybe uh we might
get around to it i know
well i think we started watching the
1976 one but i don't know if we finished
it or if we ever did like a show on it
or not maybe we didn't review it yeah
but we've seen it
yeah we saw it like fairly recently i
wanted to do mighty joe young after this
one though we can do mighty yeah i
remember i remember liking mighty joe
young best better than king kong
now i haven't seen it and i don't think
i've ever seen this one as a kid son of
kong i don't think i've seen it
yeah because mighty joe young was later
right later yeah yeah it looks a lot
better it's still black and white so i
kind of feel like it's friendly because
the thing about it is that you know even
though the original king kong obviously
like they find the gorilla and the
gorillas like you know yeah i'm eating
all you [ __ ]
um this one like i said it's a lot more
comedic and it's a lot more i mean when
they meet baby kong
when they go to skull island he's um
he's in the in the uh quicksand right
and then so they rescue him and then
like he befriends them so he just keeps
fighting like other monsters that are
terrorizing our heroes you know i mean
like he has to beat up like a big giant
bear
and like some other like another
dinosaur and all that other kind of
stuff but he's like a friendly character
he's not really seen he's and he's big
but he's not obviously as big as no he's
not that big i mean i think he's what
they said he's 12 feet tall yeah so he's
like twice the size of a person he's
about the size of mighty joe young
actually yeah so he's still
right but yeah but he just and and they
kind of like have it too where
uh the girl
who actually i don't think they ever i
was looking on wikipedia and this didn't
occur to me in the credits
they have her listed as hilda that's her
character name
but they never actually call her that in
the movie like he just calls her kid the
whole time the whole time she'll lose
her name her name's hilda though and
that's and like her dad calls her some
but he just calls her by like a pet name
or something so it's like yeah you don't
even find out they never even call her
by her name but so she's in at the
beginning like she's at uh in the circus
yeah with her dad like at this port i
think ukulele she plays and her dad has
like all these monkeys which i thought
was like kind of cool and like one of
the monkeys is dressed up like
um well all the monkeys are dressed
they're all dressed up but the one
monkey's dressed up like has the dance
of the seven fails kind of situation
like she has a little belly dancer thing
on and she's like jumping up and down
with a little veil on her yeah they're
all playing instruments and they're all
like this
oh my god that's awesome look at these
little monkeys at their little outfits
little spider monkeys yeah so she has
like a great part of the [ __ ] show i
know i really like it it's kind of like
something about a little rascals you
know what i mean
i like the monkeys that perform and yeah
they're like banging on the drops
i liked the one that was dancing like
because she was just like she's dancing
but she's basically like jumping up and
down
a little outfit
it's funny and then like
all the uh all the [ __ ] merchant
marines you know they're they have them
with both genders in there [ __ ]
watching this show and they're just not
impressed they're just like yeah
yeah
well yeah because then like you know the
monkeys i thought were the best part and
then hilda comes out and like playing
her ukulele and of course i had to do
like a tiny tim like voice because yeah
i mean
the joke is that she's not that good at
it but like she knows that she's not
that good she's not terrible i don't
know she's okay she was okay but that's
that was kind of the joke that like
nobody everybody was looking at i'm
going oh my god this is the lamest [ __ ]
ever we should we wouldn't even be here
if there was any it was [ __ ] all else to
do like in this port
i liked that actress and i liked that
character she's i did it too she's tough
and kind of scrappy
you know she'll she'll call out [ __ ]
when she sees it she'll confront people
you know you kill my father that type of
[ __ ]
um
[ __ ] she'll lie [ __ ] weasel her
way back on the ship [ __ ] all kinds
of [ __ ] you know and uh she didn't take
any [ __ ] she was kind of like marion
from yeah she was a lot more she had a
lot more character and had a lot more
like motivation yeah then because i feel
like faye i really like fay ray and i
really liked her character in the
original king kong but like you said
she's basically there just to be like a
pretty
damsel in distress and then you get the
dude and get married at the end or
whatever that's a little bit of a
[ __ ] mcguffin too
fay ray she's not really a macguffin you
know she's just she's a prop
yeah something for the she's something
for you to worry about the gorilla's got
it or the you know kong's got her yeah
you know but this this
they did the right thing though you know
they it was a woman that wrote the
script
yeah okay well she wrote the original
one too but but she didn't write the
original version of the of the original
king kong but she came in and like
streamlined it and changed it and her
version is basically what you what you
see in the final movie but she actually
wrote the screenplay for this one yeah
this this uh character she she's got
personality a little more depth to her
and actually i think that actress is
prettier than fay ray she's not dolled
up she's she's a top boy
for the era yeah i mean she is wearing
heels and [ __ ] but that's just how they
dressed back then um but um
she's not in night gowns and you know i
have her nightgowns you know or anything
like that
although that was that was a ball gown
is what that was
and they justified it by you know
basically well we we brought her here to
like shoot a movie so it's like she's
costumes and stuff whereas like in this
movie like you said she just stowed away
yeah because she was in this port and
wanted to get the [ __ ] out of there and
like her dad got killed yeah um you know
in this fight killing a drunken brawl
basically yeah by this by the dude i
actually kind of like the way they tied
this in because the dude that actually
sort of accidentally on purpose like
killed her dad
by hitting him over the head during a
drunken brawl and then setting the tent
on fire and then being like oops i'm out
that guy they tied him in with the
original movie but i say even though he
wasn't in the original movie by saying
that he was the guy that carl denham had
got the map to skull island from like in
the first movie because i think in the
first movie if i remember correctly he
said yeah i got the map from a guy but
they didn't ever show the guy or say
what the guy's name was so that's how
they tied this in the first one like
that's the dude that and then they meet
up with him again and he's like oh
you're the guy that i got the
the map from and [ __ ] like that so then
like he ends up killing her dad and
she's based like you [ __ ] like
you killed my dad and all this other
kind of stuff but
um then she just wants to get the [ __ ]
out of there because every everything's
gone like everything burned down the
monkeys were okay like she saved them
but her dad's dead so
she meets carl carl's like yeah shame
about your dad like you know and
everything but here's somebody stay here
here's some money stay here you can't go
with me and then she was like oh bummer
and then she was like i'm sneaking on
that yeah i see she gets stuck in there
anyway and then she would [ __ ] like
play dumb and then when your back's
turned she'd be snickered
she was she was manipulative but it was
like in a good way she i thought she was
a good character i did it too
and she did good um the actress did
those old [ __ ] silent movie facial
expressions and [ __ ] you know because
you know talkies were kind of new so
they still had some a lot of a lot of
carry over from the silent films and
she's hamming it up you know with the
eyebrows and all that you know
and [ __ ] you know this is
i thought she was good i think she was
one of the best things about the movie
yeah i see yeah she her and the monkeys
were my favorite part her the monkeys
and [ __ ] calm and baby calling yeah
oh carl there's this name carl the yeah
the the so-called hero i guess he's a
hero he's kind of a dick
yeah
every time baby [ __ ] does something he
yells at [ __ ] kong and [ __ ] tries to
keep put him in check and comes like oh
you know just you know i was kind of
dude man [ __ ] leaf caught leave baby
conga
what the [ __ ] and then he's all and i
have to do it off you know i have to say
too that carl
uh in this movie particularly is really
not the brightest crayon in the box
because
even before they go to skull island
because him and the captain now the
captain from the original king kong that
was the same guy right i'm pretty sure
that was the same character i think it
was the same actor so what ends up
happening is that they end up in this
port yeah they end up in this port
because this takes place only a month
after the original king kong that's when
it's only supposed to be a month has
gone by and because of all the
destruction wrought by king kong and the
original one everybody and their mom is
suing carl denham so he's like yeah i'm
gonna get the [ __ ] out of dodge uh
before i'm because i'm totally bankrupt
so him and the captain from the ship of
the original in the original movie
they're like let's go and like do
trading and so they're like going around
from port to port like trying to escape
their creditors essentially yeah so they
is that what oh this man i thought that
was a great touch because it was yeah
because you see they bring kong into
[ __ ] new york and it gets out and it
does all kinds of [ __ ] and it [ __ ]
kills people throws a woman out of her
[ __ ] bedroom
they had to call out airplanes to
[ __ ] fight it
it did all kinds of damage and then uh
beauty killed the beast that's it that's
a wrap okay everybody go home we won
in reality you get your ass [ __ ] sued
and that's what happened and that's what
happens in this one they lost everything
because they came after them for you
know [ __ ]
as they would as they would and
rightfully
rightfully came after him for you know i
guess uh you know
not malfeasance what do you call it um
endangerment and yeah because like in
all kinds of [ __ ] yeah there's no
specific law that says bringing a
gigantic ape to new york city and like
having them run around a rampage and
kill a bunch of people they were just
derelict in their [ __ ]
responsibilities you know they got loose
and it was it was they were liable
that's what i was saying reliable yeah
all that [ __ ]
and that's what would really happen
especially in new york and there's a
[ __ ] scene in there where
one of the characters is trying to serve
him [ __ ] papers to sue his ass right
and uh
he's funny
he's a good character he's a um they're
trying
you know this is new york now this is
the 30s and [ __ ] everything was
ethnic neighborhoods and there's a lot
of stereotype stuff
and he's uh uh
from the just say he's from the jewish
quarters and he's trying to [ __ ]
serve these [ __ ] papers he's oh you
got me again he goes i'm good at what i
do you know
and uh so he's he he does finally sue
him but then the dude comes later on and
goes hey they're gonna they're gonna
indict you
you know i'll get you out of here so he
met he was he safely got him out of
there remember that and you know how
they went down put him in disguised him
and [ __ ] he disguised him by like
putting a box over his head yeah
no one will
that's where the humor comes into it
because yeah he basically put was it a
box or a toaster a bucket or a bucket or
something
like
i think that's what it was i just
thought it was funny that they just put
it on his head and then he goes out in
the street and gets on the cart like
it's like it's normal yeah i thought
that was i just thought it was funny
that you know [ __ ] these old movies
they got no problems [ __ ] doing
stereotypical black people stereotypical
chinese and stereotypical irish and they
just you know stereotypes they just
thought they were funny you know back in
those days so they did stereotypical
jewish per dude they had that in there
although i wouldn't say it was like a
negative portrayal it was just a
portrayal you had jewish guys making
these movies too so that you know it was
just
all in good fun probably wouldn't fly
today but
[ __ ] it man it was the 30s
danny rowling said is there a high kill
count in this film not really really um
not compared to the first one like i
said seeing the first one after so many
years i couldn't believe how many
[ __ ] died in that movie holy
crap um king kong like ate a bunch of
[ __ ] like three people out
windows stomped on them did all kind of
stuff this one not so much um
the dad her dad dies like and that's not
even kong related because that's like at
the that's in a in a brawl and a fire
and um the guy that kills her dad like
he gets killed not by kong though he
gets killed by
does he get killed by one of the
dinosaurs or does he drown i think it's
one of the the um the [ __ ] that
killed her dad
he got eaten by the police i thought he
got yeah i think he got eaten by one of
the dinosaurs
running back to the little canoe that
they came up that they ran you know that
they remember they went there in the
tunnel and the yeah that's right where
the temple was he got this is kind of
got a temple of doom [ __ ] yeah
because they do actually find there's a
temple there like yeah they find a ted
like an old temple and because i the
natives are in this for like a second
yeah and i think it's like it's the same
guy that's like the the witch doctor
yeah um but they're only in it for like
a second because like they get to skull
island like in the little boat and all
the people come out are like man we're
pissed off at you because what you have
with king king kong and they're like bye
we're go we'll go to the other side of
the island just just don't don't kill us
so then then you don't see them anymore
so then go they go to another part of
the island and that's when they find
like i said there's other monsters in
this there's like a big bear um and
everything and danny rowling also asks
how does baby kong die baby kong dies
at the end there's like this big
earthquake something volcano whatever
the [ __ ] it is and the whole it was
island i think i'd have to see it again
yeah the island is all kind of like
going under the waves or whatever like
some atlanta's [ __ ] and so there's sea
monsters and whatnot and carl is gonna
drown
because like all the other people that
lived like the chinese guy and the and
the girl you're trying to get out of
their canoe they try to get out in the
canoe and everything's getting all
[ __ ] up and carl is like gonna drown
and
baby kong like holds him up he goes out
of the water he saves him he goes over
there and saves him and his lit his
ankle gets caught on the down yeah
that's right
and
and carl's trying to free baby kong's
leg they're both trying to free it but
then the water level rises up [ __ ]
bangkok holds him up like that as he
goes under and drowns yeah so he dies
like saving and [ __ ] carl didn't say
[ __ ] about it just swims out to the
[ __ ] dinghy and gets in oh well
i know i was just kind of like yeah and
the thing about it what i was going to
say earlier was writing all tight it
wasn't was that carl i mean it was very
rushed you could tell that it was very
rushed it's still a good movie but you
could tell that it was kind of like they
didn't have a lot of time to like do
more drafts and stuff but i was going to
say that earlier on like carl
even though baby kong like obviously did
some stuff to like save them like fought
the bear off like killed the bear and
carl's just like well do you think that
baby kong is like trying to protect them
like duh dude it's like are you he's
like not really bright well like i said
he's not really bright too because he
always said yeah hilda was like yeah of
course
she knew monkeys she'd be she'd been
working with monkeys for many years in
the circus but yeah what i was saying
about carl not being that smart was
obviously one he didn't understand that
baby kong was like friends of theirs
like and was returning the favor because
they had pulled him out of the quicksand
like when they first found him but also
even before they got to skull island
when he was talking to the [ __ ] that
killed hilda's dad
he was trying to get off the [ __ ] uh
out of this port too and he's just like
oh there's a
treasure on skull island yeah that's it
i'm like obviously he's making a story
up and carl's like what treasure okay
let's go you know what i mean i'm like
oh my god it turned out there was you
were a giant idiot well yeah but um i
don't think he knew it but he didn't no
no he said he didn't know where it was
he just heard that no but he said later
on that he's like there wasn't any
treasure you know what i mean he was
full of [ __ ] it just happened that they
found like yeah it was like it was like
a big diamond thing like in an idol you
had that big wall there so yes there's
going to be more there was a damn temple
well that's all this stuff is kind of
what made me think just the tone of the
movie the subject matter what was
happening to me it was reminding me of
indiana jones yeah it was much more like
that kind of like temple of doom or
indiana jones one
you know because when
when jenny first saw the [ __ ]
treasure she goes is it the ark of the
covenant it looked kind of like that
right
yeah i was like don't open that your
face is gonna melt off yeah but yeah so
i mean that's kind of the thing it's and
i will say too that it takes a while for
them to get to skull island like it's i
think it's like half the movie like
before they even get to scholar yeah
like the whole first part
that's what i'm saying like and and like
i said there was a bunch of stuff in the
script that they couldn't afford to film
like a lot more like dinosaur stuff now
they did use a lot of the um the figures
like the the stop motion figures like
from the first movie like some of the
dinosaurs and [ __ ] like that but they
did have some new ones like i said like
the bear and
like the big bear and everything that
was new i don't think that was in the
first one but they did use some of the
dinosaurs over again like i think one
was in the water and [ __ ] like that i
put it there with you know
the the the the sin bad movies
yeah about like that i mean not as epic
and scary
but it's it's trying to be that that's
it's a prototype just sauna just on a
much much lower budget well it's 1930s
that and that too it's 1930s i think
that's the main problem not so much
budget the thing about the first king
kong was that you have to think that
yeah it looked really awesome like with
that big wall and the jungle sets and
everything like that but all that stuff
most of that stuff wasn't even built for
king kong specifically it was built for
the most dangerous game and they just
used it for king kong because they had
it and they were like so they just
dressed it a little bit different right
so it wasn't like you know they built it
like they purpose built it for that
movie so i kind of feel like i don't
know so like what happened with this one
they had nine months to make it and they
had like i think half the budget
um
so i think they did as well as they
could with what they had i think it was
a good idea to go in a completely
different direction than the original
king kong
like his original king kong is much more
a horror movie like it had a little bit
of humor in it but not really and like i
said a whole bunch of people died um so
it was a lot more like an adventure
horror movie whereas this one is an
adventure movie but it's a lot funnier
adventure serial movie yeah
1930s which that's what that's what
indiana jones was copying and homaging
those yes so it's it's like that
it's got a it's it's got comedy in there
but it's not slapstick in a way it's
just
they're lightening the mood they're the
uh that they're just trying to approach
the king topic from a new angle so it's
not repeating the first one i think
people probably liked it but they they
made a big mistake killing off baby kong
so yeah see i was not expecting that
because
like i said i was pretty sure i hadn't
seen it in a long time so i didn't
remember what had happened because i
didn't see it since i was a kid and i'm
pretty sure one of you guys i don't
remember who it was but said that that
uh baby kong didn't die at the end but
he does though yeah and and then i was
like that kind of like bummed me out
because
the movie was kind of like it's not a
laugh a minute or anything but it had
like a lot more humor in it and then for
them to just go serious at the end and
just kill him off
a little shitty it was dumb because you
you now you killed your money maker it
should have ended
with them being rescued by a bigger ship
and and that son of kong could fit on
that ship and they pulled them out baby
call go no yeah
rescue him with a damn
witch or something that or you know what
i mean that you know pull him up out or
he gets free there's no reason why he
even had to
you know
uh get his leg caught you could have
ended up in you could have made the
story so they all ended up being rescued
by a bigger vessel
and that they it ends with them heading
back to north to to new york because see
you can now make a third installation
years later of what happens when he gets
to new york and he's now older type of
deal baby kong takes manhattan
baby cog is the size of [ __ ] his dad
now you know what i mean they got him
somewhere and he's cool
all right
but then they get attacked by something
else and then that was way godzilla went
yeah where godzilla is now
defending japan
from white people
which i think is basically what they're
talking about white people in their
atomic bombs
making bigger and bigger monsters yeah
yeah yeah that's yeah right that's
actually probably they should have done
that like i said i don't really know but
like we were talking about this when we
were watching the movie last night and i
think i brought this up a little bit on
the king kong show on sunday was that
really
there i'm not saying there weren't
sequels i don't know if this is actually
the first case of a sequel
but like to a movie i mean people knew
the concept because it did happen like
in writing and stuff like that but i
think this was maybe the first time that
it happened on this large of a scale and
so they didn't really they weren't
thinking they weren't really thinking
long term they were just thinking kind
of like hey that movie was really
successful let's quickly do another one
right and i guess they killed off baby
kong at the end because they're like
well
king kong died at the end of the first
one and that was like super successful
so let's just do that again dumb idea
which like i said they weren't really
thinking oh maybe we can make another
one like a year down the line yeah where
like you said he could have been and
then you could have introduced like
other monsters if there's if there's
islands out there that has to have
things like kong on it then that means
there's other islands sure
all right there's other islands that
have things that are worse
all right
what's going to happen when these things
attack america
think about it okay can it get into a
giant gorilla yeah you're going to have
to have a giant gorilla
[Laughter]
[ __ ] defend in america
and mexico khan
america you just say north america and
then yeah we can get canada in there too
see machine guns aren't enough you need
to [ __ ] call out kong just ask the
japanese whenever they get in danger man
[ __ ] you know it's kaiju express man
it's destroy all monsters okay japan
being attacked by 30 or 40
giant monsters
you know it's [ __ ]
had they done that there's a chance
where
five or ten years later archaea will you
know we can we can come back and we can
do part three now we need to start
hyping this all right and you would have
had kaiju in the 30s and early 40s yeah
see
world war ii was happening so you wanted
to get that in the 30s before world war
ii started well they didn't know world
war ii was gonna start but
yeah that had been pretty weird
before world war ii started
but uh it would have been better are you
nostradamus yeah
it had been better if they had that
thing out by you know
37 or so
36 yeah and now you got kaiju giant
monsters well the thing about it though
i kind of feel like it might not
technically be kaiju because
um
i think i mentioned this sunday king
kong is just a big giant gorilla he
doesn't have any magic powers he's not
like radioactive or anything because i
feel like godzilla and all those
monsters and stuff because they were
created by radiation like some of them
had
not supernatural powers but they had raw
mutants yeah they had like mutant type
powers
where
king kong was just the only mutation was
like he was just really big yeah he was
a natural creature he didn't yeah he
didn't like have any weird powers
otherwise it was because
it was too big
it would just be an american version of
it would just be giant monsters giant
creatures they wouldn't have they
wouldn't have to be you know fire
breathing or
mutants or any way they would just be
stuck they were shooting lightning or
whatever the [ __ ] no
you see it would be
it would make sense that the way that
that one ended
that you you're now
son of kong is now friends with mankind
he's back and he they built a habitat
for him in the united states yeah see
that would be good he's got a whole
theme park it's kind of like jurassic
park people pay to come see it he's now
wealthy yeah okay and they got he's got
they got a big old kong and he's
chilling well all of a sudden from one
of these other islands something bad
happens or mankind now needs cog
to help
all right and because he's living around
people he can't help
maybe they even got where he speaks
simon i was just gonna say so they
taught him sign language right and then
and then because they knew they could do
that in the 30s
they probably even thought of that they
would but you could arm him you could
give him a big old club or a sword or
something you know what i mean a shield
it would be like a superhero movies
cut him loose man give him a little
outfit yeah
you might want you might not want to
give him that until like the grand
finale like he's fighting a giant turtle
yeah something was ridiculous
that would never happen he would never
find a big camera yeah well he's
eventually going to have to [ __ ] but
gamers
shell somehow you know what i mean
and i had to make him something that's
what the japanese would have done that's
what they were doing okay we're gonna
have to equip him yeah so you you got a
whole stories you could tell right there
america should have been up on that but
they weren't thinking they weren't
thinking they weren't thank you hugo
said i think there was a rule in the
academy back then where you have to kill
the monster at the end maybe that's what
it was because it was just gonna be
punished yeah that that was definitely a
rule and that was not evil that was
something that came in with the haze
code but yeah see i think that you could
have got around him because he wasn't he
was a good guy he was a good guy he
didn't do anything bad to anybody so you
could have had like a kaiju and they
already had superheroes at this time
they had
so they could have done it they it was
just that they were not they they were
just trying to get it over with i think
like hey let's make this make something
yeah they just wanted to cash in they
weren't realizing that you could make a
[ __ ] extended universe they didn't
think that way yeah not really like i
said it's not i think people nowadays
think it's like oh my god all the
sequels but it's like what's the
universal monster movies and all that
man they made [ __ ] [ __ ] tons of
sequels to those yeah son of
frankenstein son of dracula you know
[ __ ] baby dracula yeah that's funny
because they made like they made them
all the time and then like abbott and
costello meet frankenstein it was just
it was ridiculous they didn't build in
any continuity into anything no they
were just like oh this is a great movie
then to end it and they're [ __ ] the
monsters dead now the next [ __ ] time
you have to remake that movie how are
you going to bring him back there's like
we're just going to pretend that [ __ ]
didn't happen i killed him in a [ __ ]
first place what are you doing like i
said they didn't they didn't think like
long term like i said they i i feel like
maybe that's like a newer concept
because nowadays everybody
i feel like if you're making a movie
particularly if it's superheroes or
monsters like you have this kind of like
long-term plan it's like where it's
going to be this whole overarching world
and this whole of our overarching story
and i kind of feel like they weren't
doing that as much
they didn't even they were not in movies
anyway they were even [ __ ] that [ __ ]
up in the late 80s i remember when that
first tim burton batman came out we saw
that in the theater i [ __ ] loved that
[ __ ] with jack nicholson as a joker i
thought it was just the [ __ ] best
movie ever at that time you know we're
just this is [ __ ] a trip man you know
batman no way you know because batman
was some [ __ ] hokey [ __ ] you know
adam west you know that's what we that's
how we picture batman though they're
just showing us this badass cool idea
batman and [ __ ] the joker the joker
was [ __ ] impressive what do they do
they kill him
yeah they kill him at the end of the
movie and i was like that was [ __ ]
dumb
that was [ __ ] dumb how can you kill
the [ __ ] joker the series is over
it's over
because
if you ever even looked at the [ __ ]
tv series which we would watch the tv
series we liked it it was fun we were
kids the joker always comes back you
don't kill off your villains
yeah why would you why would you do that
don't kill the villains the villains are
the best part
they're just always temporarily defeated
they get locked up okay that's it but
then they get escaped so they got to do
it over and over again that's what i
mean it's like if you kill you got me
last time batman but you know this is
this you know he's back that way you can
always revive the series well how good
were those other bad other batman movies
been i mean [ __ ]
the one with the one with catwoman was
great and penguin but how that would
have been so much better if the joker
was still out there and would show up
jack nicholson imagine if jack nicholson
showed up in that movie i mean i guess
if you really wanted to go out there you
could say like you'd kill him off and
then bring him back as a zombie in one
yes
[Laughter]
no
[ __ ] like that you just made
kaiju realized that you just you don't
kill them
you don't kill them at all yeah you just
put them like in stasis they're going to
stay sisters they're like frozen at the
bottom of the arctic or some [ __ ] they
get buried and you know you're not
really quite sure what happened to them
yeah so they can always come back that
kind of stuff
well yeah i mean that's kind of the
whole thing why are you getting rid of
your money makers your villains are the
ones that really make the [ __ ] money
so yeah so it seems like while they had
the right idea like king kong i'm not
saying that they shouldn't have killed
king kong at the end of king kong
because i think that's a really good
ending even though it's really sad but i
think that was kind of like the whole
point of the movie but then when they
did son of kong i was like okay that's a
good idea so he had a baby they don't
really say where's the mama they just
assume yeah where's where's the extended
where's the breeding population mom kong
yeah there's a movie they did now they
did make a horrible horrible horrible
movie in the 70s i think called queen
kong okay which i think was a british
movie i haven't
what is that the one that had lipstick
it might have yeah i think it had
lipstick on it i haven't seen i didn't
sit through the whole thing but remember
brandon tennold on his uh on his channel
he talked about it on there and it was
like a 20 or 30 minute video and it
looks atrocious but i also kind of want
to see it so yeah but they never did do
a mom kong did they they never think
about that
it's all i don't know why they never do
i don't know i guess later like hammer
and stuff like that did like daughter of
dracula and stuff like that but it's
usually like son of whatever yeah but
they never think about like who the mom
is yeah it's a mystery zack's in there
freaking out oh tom's talking about
jewish guys gonzaga's
his crush on jewish boys leave that men
alone leave him alone zach
[Laughter]
danny rowling said let's just say baby
kong pulled a harry houdini escape act
and swam to inner hollow earth and
survived see i mean that's
they could have done that because they
didn't absolutely they just assumed that
he died you did see his little hand like
yeah and stuff like that so i guess if
they really wanted to bring him back
then they could they could write somehow
like he swam like he found like an air
pocket or some [ __ ] yeah it would have
made more sense to have a kind of a
happy ending though
yeah it would have fit more in with the
tone i mean i told him i didn't i wasn't
bothered by king kong dying at the end
of king kong because that it was a more
serious movie
and it was like i said that was kind of
like the point of it they brought him
out of his habitat and he got [ __ ]
over whereas this one was a lot more
light-hearted but then they still killed
him at the end even though he was
friendly yeah so to me that just seemed
that's why i was kind of like mad at the
end and like and i asked pookie like i
was like do you believe that [ __ ] do you
believe that [ __ ] pokey
she didn't believe it she couldn't
believe it either
uh when he said ooh jenny i love the new
wig thank you this is actually like not
a new one a new one it's an old one
i just haven't worn it in a really long
time because i have shorter ones now
but
uh dana rolling said i believe they did
a mock on called big mama's house just
kidding um yeah so
danny rolling is also coming up with
like a bunch of new
like
baby conglomerate versus anunnaki giants
and stuff yeah which yeah they could
have gone in a lot of different
directions but they didn't really figure
it out
the japanese saw the potential yeah they
understood what they what we what they
did you know what we were dealing with
they were like they [ __ ] that up they
should do this and this and that and
that's what all that like gojira the
very first one it's a serious movie it's
like up there it's like you know
yeah it's always kind of scary remember
i haven't seen it yeah it is it is yeah
it's it's a way more it's not funny it's
not yeah it's not like so black and
white yeah
i actually really liked the first yeah
we got to see that one again
gojira was good and then they knew they
knew they didn't they didn't make the
mistakes that uh we made with kong where
you kill off your [ __ ] monsters and
then you kill off the prodigy and
[ __ ]
no you you uh
you know you you you let them survive
it's a lot better to fight another fight
another day sure make another movie they
[ __ ] made it well [ __ ] at the end of
this one
they didn't just kill baby kong they
they sunk the whole island the whole
island so all the dinosaurs everybody no
see all the natives they didn't even
mention that japanese knew better they
had an island off their coast called
monster island that they could always
access and they'd get a new monster out
of there they knew japanese know how to
make money
sergeant deadhead said tom's not pookie
no pookie is the kitty cat she's the
kitty cat yeah which you sometimes you
can see her little stumpy tail like
going around behind us um
i saw someone oh danny rowling said
gorgo was the adjacent english godzilla
knockoff yeah i saw that on mystery
science theater so i've actually seen
gorgeous
irish it is irish it's irish yeah it's
irish yeah or at least i should come up
with that oh [ __ ] i don't know if the
british made it and it just happened
that gorgo like attacked
the
attacked ireland
but it had some american actors in it
though it had the dude that was in what
the [ __ ] was that dude's name that dude
was in some was in uh
was he in 2001 a space honestly i want
to thank i remember seeing it as a kid
and liking it but then i saw it later on
and and saw that it was i remember
thinking that it was just mediocre
mediocre there was something about the
tone it was too uh but i haven't seen it
a long time it's okay it's not great um
like i said it's the swedish one was
even worse
they did that one on mystery theater too
like the new one yeah what the [ __ ] was
that called uh
the swedes can't make movies
well that's not true no they can't make
monster moves yeah they could make them
they can make other kinds of the tone is
too serious and too uh
well no the weird thing about it is that
most of it's like really serious but
then there's like one character in there
that's like a total comic relief yeah
his like eyes are bugging out and it's
like really really strange
what the [ __ ] is the name of that thing
i saw it it was on the newer mystery
science theater the one that was on
netflix they basically fight a chinese
dragon
yeah a chinese dragon in in sweden
john gore said gorga was a tear-jerker
as a kid with the baby monster being
saved by its mother yeah that's kind of
that i don't think that was the first
time that troop had been done
but yeah they find the monster and they
put it in the circus or whatever and i
remember the circus is called dorkans
yeah like that was the guy's last name
was dorkan and i'm like jesus christ did
you not workshop this at all see the
british were good at [ __ ] they were real
good
they made real good movies they had real
good actors they still happened to to
this day they got a strong theater oh
they actually teach their actors how to
act before they put them in movies uh
you know looking
anyway uh
they had a lot of good movies there was
one that i remember and they could pull
a cheap movie out of nothing and it
would make an impression on you
especially when you were a kid one i
remember was the day of the triffids
that i remember that [ __ ] scaring me
i haven't seen in a long time um i saw
it implants i saw it a couple uh months
ago because i covered it for my uh for
my other series is it is any good um
i don't love it to be honest it has like
it has its moments
but it wasn't it wasn't as scary as i
remembered the book is way better all
right but um that'd be a good idea yeah
that needs to be redone it's kind of
like a zombie apocalypse but it's alien
plants taking over i thought they did
remake that though you'd have to do that
the right way did they make it i don't
know if they did a good job i don't know
i mean maybe they didn't remake it maybe
i'm thinking of something else but i
didn't know if they'd done another
adaptation because the novel was by um
john windham yeah the same guy that
wrote the midwich cuckoos which was the
book that um
what's the what's the what's the movie
about the kids that with the white hair
like
village of the damn yeah uh that was the
same author yeah and the british of
course basically made the the old star
wars movies in case you guys didn't know
that was all [ __ ] stupid most of that
studio work was done up in england they
made all the [ __ ] sets and [ __ ] did a
good job on that hell yeah
british
craftsmanship well yeah i mean i like a
lot of british actors i like a lot of
british films to be honest yeah yeah you
couldn't do that the united states it
would cost too much and then the [ __ ]
studios would tell you oh you can't do
this oh you can't do it no
go down to england man [ __ ] they'll
make some cool [ __ ] they had experience
with doctor who they making crazy [ __ ]
you know
[ __ ] old tom becker doctor who which
i gotta get i gotta jump back on those
and [ __ ] finish him yeah i was gonna
say you you got brit box
for the express purpose of watching
all the all the doctor do wow
you should make it that would be so
funny if you did like a real cheap jack
sci-fi show yeah
who are you man i like to do
like like tom baker but i'm short
yeah
oh my god yeah like an american version
that'd be hilarious
bluetooth dude says godzilla's son
godzilla looks like ernest borgnine he
doesn't it is earnest board and i didn't
you know
he's such a good that's him yeah danny
rolling off he said in all these monster
films they never show the creatures
taking a dump and how big their turds
are which would be funny to see just
saying actually i kind of there i
remember i made that um comment when we
were watching the first king kong i was
like why
like you would think you'd be stepping
in like dinosaur [ __ ] all over this
[ __ ] eye that old that old comedy
movie called caveman the dude falls in a
giant [ __ ] dinosaur turd remember
that yeah i mean it happens in combat
i'm not saying but yeah yeah it doesn't
it does it happen in jurassic park do
you want to say yeah probably maybe it
does like somebody falls into like a big
giant giant dinosaur flop
all right so we've been going almost an
hour yeah and
i'm starving yeah and uh i got made yeah
so
uh thanks everybody for dropping by son
of kong is and the original king kong
are both on hbmax if you have that so in
their little classic section so tomorrow
is wednesday and that means that it's
gonna be our main show and we're doing
true crime once again we're doing the
tool box killers that's right and make
sure you brings you drinks and we're
gonna drink that whole show yeah oh and
like don't forget on friday the
sidetrack show you said you were gonna
buy that's right colt 45 and [ __ ] like
that i wrote it down so don't forget
okay just remind me tomorrow we're gonna
we're gonna do like the shitty drinks
taste test on friday night's show on
friday
that's right 45. we'll do that so we'll
do that on the friday night show because
like tomorrow night's show is going to
be like too much of a bummer so uh
because it's going to be true crime but
it's a pretty horrific but uh yeah john
gore said bring your tools oh boy i just
i i was reading some notes i've heard
about the case before but like i started
reading through it i'm like oh man this
is gonna this one's gonna be grim but
yeah so uh yeah so thanks everybody for
dropping by we will see you guys again
tomorrow evening
bye